um the longest relationship you've been
in is three years right right um
in the last year during the pandemic
sure did you see anybody i've seen
plenty of people go outside i see people
yeah but in a sexual way uh yeah i look
at uh anthony
i mean michael b jordan in a sexual way
i look at i've seen him oh yeah yeah
yeah oh you know him personally no
through photos not yet yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah you so you're you're you're you you
um
can i ask you this sure we might have to
cut this part you can ask whatever you
want i don't know okay okay
but then don't cut it off i really
really respect the fact that you don't
talk about it by the way yeah that's
really cool because you there's certain
things that i like fully regret that i
can never take back right i'm like god
is this even still our relationship or
does it belong to everyone else right
there's that sense of like oh [ __ ] i
gave too much
i understand yeah i understand i
understand and i will i will
i will shift my you can keep poking at
it because i have fun with it no no no
i'll tell you why i don't want to poke
at it
because none of our [ __ ] business
none of my our business but not number
one number two it's like um i always i'm
always mesmerized by people that um
aren't like me you know whereas
you know everything that i say or do
is on my sleeve
i just reveal everything a little too
much almost he reveals not just things
about himself he reveals things about
loved ones
partners got it um family members
everything so we're here we're just like
just here just [ __ ] with our dicks in
our hands like why did he say that about
me
it's all he's going through like a a
tour every single podcast just like
giving our deepest darkest i love it
what were you going to ask me because
i'm kind of curious of what you were
because you wanted to cut it what was it
all right we have to cut this part out
but i will all right so
because you're an attractive young lady
right and i think that you have a lot of
fan you know
some of your fan base are guys that
think that you're cute and stuff like
that so maybe you know i know a lot of
um
comics male comics who don't talk about
being in a relationship because you know
i mean they want to keep that
demographic out there wondering or
whatever is that it some of it uh that's
a part of it a part of it's like you
gotta
keep that illusion up that's that's what
i was asking right yeah yeah another
part of it is also
when
from what i've seen in the past once you
say that you're dating someone everyone
starts bombarding that person yeah you
know
and a lot of the people that i date
don't want that
and it just gets kind of creepy
sometimes i remember one of them i
posted a picture with him didn't say
anything but he got like really crazy
messages like i'll kill you are you oh
yeah so i just want to keep that out
sure i would never ask specific names
you know because i'm very polite right
sure yeah but i don't have the opposite
if he ever leaves me no one will have me
oh no i say that all the time like
either i have you or god will have you
you know make a choice yeah yeah yeah
but i also don't like to deal with the
whole like
youtube video because i came from
youtube and i don't like doing the whole
video like hey guys you know we broke up
but we still love each other and we
respect each other i don't want to do
that yeah
yeah because i know a friend um
matthews do you know her
uh i know her from yeah i know she is i
never met her yeah so mannin made this
her marriage such a big deal like the
wedding and the whole thing and then
like months later all of a sudden he's
no longer in photos right
and then all of a sudden she had to do
like
explanation videos
of like you know i love her she's very
talented but you know like that's
exhausting that's exhausting
like back track and now like because
like when you're putting your [ __ ] out
there it's only really like super
shallow level right right they don't
really know the intricacies of your
relationship so now that they see that
you're broken up then you have to
explain the intricacies and that's just
the worst that's my [ __ ] worst
nightmare right i i dated someone
briefly that was in uh entertainment
also
and when they noticed that we weren't
posting things together anymore it was
just every day hey where is he where is
he where is he where is he where is he
and he's just like i don't want to deal
with that
i just don't make anything public ever
yeah we're [ __ ] you and i i know well
no i mean i think we're a different
thing though i think that you and i
i think that you and i started this
relationship
and then we did this podcast and we're
okay with
and some of the things i've said i
apologize
okay i just want to say you know that
some of the things i said okay was um
really crazy
and i apologize
and i i'm never gonna do that again
okay so in the beginning i said some
crazy ass [ __ ] right like you would talk
about like the color of my vagina oh
that's lovely it's beautiful yeah yeah i
bet it's a beautiful color right
it's not even like one of those like oh
it's just pink it has to like you have
to get really pink fancy with it
yeah yeah yeah yeah mom
mom
because there's like there's there's
people who are like oh it's green but
then there's other people it's like it's
seafoam green
i love seafoam green wait wait wait
there are vaginas that are green no
we're just talking about it's not pink
because hey guys we're gonna take a
really quick break to share some of our
favorite sponsors with you
better
you guys you know what's worth more than
gold what happiness oh yeah yeah